大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
2026年春天,
史丹佛的一間教室裡,
一個45歲的男人站在頭螢幕前面,
打開了一個他18年前寫過的東西,
那是他27歲那年做的第一個產品,
當年他募了資,
僱了10個人,
寫了兩年才寫完,
就把公司賣掉,
而他這一次做的事情是,
用一個每個月200美元的訂閱方案,
把同一個東西從頭再做一次,
他花了大約5天。
這是史丹佛CS153這門課的第五堂
而這門課的第五到第八堂
站上講臺的是四個位置完全不同的人
今天我們就把這四堂課一起上完
這個人叫Gary Tan
現在是Y Combinator的總裁
即執行長
Y Combinator是硅谷最有名的新創育成機構
你可以把它想成新創公司的補習班
加上第一筆錢的來源
2008年夏天
他自己也是那裡的學生
帶著一個叫Posturas的部落格產品進去
他們前後募了大約1000萬美元
僱了10個人
花2年把所有軟體寫完
2012年3月賣給了Twitter
18年之後
他站在史丹佛的講臺上說
他把同一個東西重做了一次
這一次沒有團隊
沒有募資
一個每個月200美元的訂閱方案
他花了大約5天
我要先講清楚
這不是一支說AI讓你變厲害的影片
因為接下來這4堂課
4個站在完全不同位置的人
會各自證明同一件事
一個人手上的槓桿確實變得非常長了
然後他們又會各自把這根槓桿的價碼講出來
上一集我們看完了這門課的前四堂
那四個人
微軟的執行長
OpenAI的執行長
顧樂觀基礎設施的技術長
還有一位前執行長
講的其實是同一件事
這個時代的權力正在往少數幾家公司集中
他們每一個人都說這件事很危險
卻沒有人說得出避開它的方法
上一集問的問題是
權力集中在誰手上
這一集問的是下一個問題
那我還剩多少籌碼
這門課的第五到第八堂換了四個人
第五堂是剛剛那位Gary Teng
還有Guy Combinator的管理合夥人Diana Hu
第六堂是NVIDIA的創辦人
即執行長黃仁勳
第七堂是General Matter的創辦人
即執行長Scott Nolan
那是一家幫核電廠做藍調的公司
第八堂是Andresen Horowitz的
共同創辦人Ben Horowitz
公司算力 能源 資本
他們四個人的答案疊起來
會變成一句聽起來不太舒服的話
你手上的槓桿是真的變長了
但那個支點是租來
我們先把這個對照看仔細一點
因為它是這堂課最實在的一組東西
2008年那一次
他要做的事情包含這些
說服投資人給他籤面試
並顧盡10個工程師
租辦公室
分配工作
開會對齊
然後每一行程師都要有人親手寫出來
兩年之後產品才算完成
2026年這一次
他訂了一個叫Cloud Code Max的方案
每個月200美元
Cloud Code
你可以理解成一個會自己
動手改你程式的助理
你把要做的事情交代給他
他自己去讀你的專案
自己寫自己跑測試
做完再回來給你看
他說他這一次不是坐在那裡打字
他是在核準
所以真正變料不是打字速度
而是生產的單位
以前一個產品要一個團隊才做得出來
現在是一個人加上一套系統
而這整堂課接下來講的東西
全部都是這句話的後文
他講了一件更誇張的事
他說在2025年年底之前
他其實已經很久沒有自己寫程式了
當上Y Combinator的總裁之後
他的工作是看人
看公司
講話
然後他重新開始寫
而且是用剛剛那種方式寫
他做了兩個放在Github上
任何人都可以免費拿去用的專案
一個叫Stack 一個叫Gbrand
Github是全世界工程師放程式碼的地方
上面有一個按鈕叫做星星
就像你在社群平臺上按收藏
一顆星代表一個人覺得這個東西值得留著
他站在史丹佛講臺上那一天
這兩個專案加起來大概是10萬顆星
我在做這支影片的時候去看了一次
已經是16萬
多出來的那6萬顆
是他講完那句話之後才長出來的
那個速度不是一個形容詞
他在你查資料的這段時間裡還在繼續動
不過他自己給的量尺
比新星數保守的多
他講得很清楚
程式碼的行數是可以造假的
他還為了這件事公開道過歉
真正的量尺只有一個問題
有人在付錢嗎
而這一段裡最有趣的一個細節
是模型自己還沒有跟上這個現實
他把一件工作交給Cloud Code
順口問了一句這要多久
模型回答他大概三個星期
他按下核准
一個小時之後就作文了
模型是拿人類過去寫下的文字訓練出來的
所以他腦袋裡那把估算時間的尺
還是人類的尺
他也贏了另一個人的說法
一位前Amazon
前Google的工程師Steve Yegi
今年2月寫過一篇文章
主張認真用agent的人
生產力會比只開著聊天室創的人
高上10倍到100倍
agent的中文常翻成代理人
指的是那種你交代一次
他自己一路做到遠的城市
這裡也要說清楚
Yegi不是Anthropic的員工
這篇文章是他訪談了
大約40位Anthropic的人之後
寫下的個人判斷
不是任何公司亮出來的數據
這樣講下來
你可能會想問一個很合理的問題
那產出的東西品質呢
覺得這一段是他整場最誠實的地方
有人說AI寫出來的程式都是垃圾
他沒有反駁
他說沒有錯會有垃圾
那就是預設值
他的原話是
這正是你在打造自己那條產線的時候
要對抗的東西
他的具體做法是把測試覆蓋率
壓在八成到九成之間
測試覆蓋率的意思是
另外寫的那些檢查程式
涵蓋了你多少比例的程式碼
你可以把它想成
工廠出貨前的抽檢
抽檢的比例愈高
壞掉的東西溜出去的機會就愈低
所以它真正的意思是
一個人變成一百個人
靠的不是模型比較聰明
是你自己蓋了一條
有檢查站的產線
等一下那胡補了一句更硬的話
他說還有人停在去年那種用法
就是開一個聊天室窗
把答案複製貼上
他的判斷是
那種用法接下來會很辛苦
到了這一堂最好的轉折
他說他認真去搭那一套
agent系統之後
做著做著
發現自己在重新發明一個很老的東西
公司
他先寫了一堆叫skill的檔案
那其實就是一份一份的作業手冊
寫清楚某一件事該怎麼做
對應到公司裡
那是一個會做某件事的員工
他發現事情一多就會亂
所以他做了一個叫resolver的東西
負責決定哪一件事該交給誰
那就是組織圖
再來他發現有些事會沒有人接受
所以他又加了一道檢查
確認每一件進來的事情都真的有人負責
那是集合合法尊
法尊的意思是
確認你做的每一件事
都合乎規定
最後他還得確認
該啟動的時候
真的有啟動
於是他做了觸發測試
那是績效考核
他講完這一串之後
說了一句話
他說我坐在你們
這個位置的時候
完全不懂
為什麼那麼多公司
要花那麼多時間
在集合合法尊上面
現在我45歲
做了一堆這種系統
光是為了讓他們能動
就花掉這麼多時間
我終於懂了
你以為公司裡
那些凡人的流程是官僚
其實他們是
人類版的錯誤處理
迪亞娜胡接著
把這件事講得更系統一點
她說今天的公司
是一個開回路的系統
開回路的意思是
你把指令送出去
但是你不知道結果
也沒有東西
自動把偏差修回來
公司裡的資訊活在哪裡
活在某個人的腦袋裡
活在私訊裡
活在沒有寫下來的會議裡
還有活在一種
叫做感覺的東西里
開回路系統的問題是
誤差會一點一點累積
等到有人發現的時候
整臺車已經開到路邊去了
閉迴路不一樣
它一直在量
一直在修
誤差被壓在範圍裡
他說AI真正的機會
是把公司從開回路變成閉迴路
讓他系統有權限
讀到公司產生的每一份東西
他引了一篇Jack Dorsey
和紅杉資本的Rolof Bosa
今年3月和寫的文章
題目叫做從階層到智慧
那篇文章的論點是
公司之所以會長出一層一層的主管
根本原因是一個人
只帶了那種三到八個人
AI現在可以接手主管
在做的那一件事
也就把資訊上上下下傳一遍
文章裡有一句話很直接
不需要一個長設的中階管理層
不過Dynahoo也畫了一條線
他說有樣東西不能外包
他的原話是
寫成式的成本會歸零
但是判斷什麼是好東西的品位不會
而品位在一套系統裡面的具體形態
叫做EVO
EVO就是評測的意思
你可以把它想成你自己出的一份考卷
題目是你的產品真正在乎的那些狀況
答案是你認為好的答案
他特別強調
烏上那些公開的通用評測
像MMLU那種考模型知識廣度的題庫
完全沒有辦法告訴你
你產品到底有沒有用
這一段也連到他講的一個數字
而這個數字他在課堂上講錯了
我覺得應該講出來
他說AI原生的新創
每一個員工帶來100萬到200萬美元的營收
而像Salesforce這種大型上市公司
每一個員工帶來的營收不到6位數
實際上Salesforce最新一個會計年度
換算下來是50幾萬美元
所以那個差距沒有他講的10倍那麼大
是2到4倍
差距還在
只是沒有那麼戲劇化
公司實際上長什麼樣子
他們在課堂上舉了三家
第一家叫Salient
做的是車貸的貸後服務
第二家叫Happy Robot
做的是貨運物流
卡車調度
那個世界裡有大量的電話
來回確認
第三家叫Reducto
做的是把PDF
這種給人看的文件
變成機器讀得懂的資料
他們引用Reducto的理由
值得記下來
因為所有的agent
都要讀文件
把文件處理做好
等於把所有人的記憶都變好了
而這三家有一個共同的做法
Nahal叫他臥底
這些創辦人本來完全不懂金融
也不懂物流
所以他們直接跑去那個行業裡跟班
甚至真的去上班
把流程學到骨子裡
他給了一句我覺得最實用的話
現在流程不在訓練資料裡
模型讀過整個網際網路
但他沒讀過一家貨運公司的調度員
早上七點在想什麼
這一段最後補一個數字
YC官方後來公佈
2026年3月那一屆
整屆平均每週的營收成長是14%
是YC歷史上最快的一屆
第六堂課講臺上換了人
展上去的是NVIDIA的
創辦人繼執行長黃仁勳
而這一趟是整個系列裡最不客氣的一場
開場沒多久
主持人就丟了一個有點難堪的問題
2026年春天
有一份內部備忘錄外流出去
上面寫著XAI的訓練利用率大概只有11%
簽名的是XAI的總裁
他自己用的形容詞是低到難堪
因為業界一般落在3乘5到4乘5之間
這個數字的專有名詞叫MFU
中文可以說成模型算力利用率
白話講就是
你花大錢買回來的那一整批晶片
在訓練的時候
真正有在算的比例是多少
所以11%的意思是
將近九成的時間
那些非常昂貴的晶片
是閒著的
主持人把他問到黃仁勳臉上
本來想聽他怎麼修理這個數字
而他的回答是
我個人想要低的那個數字
而且我一直都想要
有事情是把這把尺本身推翻掉
他說MFU這個指標
根本就是錯的
理由是這樣
一座大型機房
在任何一個時刻
一定有某一個東西是瓶頸
可能是算力不夠
可能是記憶體的頻寬不夠
可能記憶體塞不下
也可能是網路太慢
你不知道下一秒卡住的會是哪一項
所以正確的做法是每一項都配置的比你平常需要的更多
他說在對的那一刻
機器會充到百分之百
但是那只有很短一段時間
而如果在那段時間裡
你沒有那些平常顯著的算力
那段短的時間就會變成很長的時間
他還給了一個很好懂的說法
以前大家不懂車的時候會問你的車幾匹馬力
現在還有誰這樣問
你問的是這臺車跑起來怎麼樣
零件的規格不是答案
整臺機器交出來的表現才是
這裡有一個很值得放在一起看的對照
上一集裡
Google管基礎設施的技術長
講過一句話
如果我們有容量在那邊閒著
不信吧
同一年
同一個產業
兩個站在最頂端的人
對浪費的定義剛好相反
那他為什麼會這樣想
因為他這輩子在做的事情
就是拒絕別人畫好的框
從1964年
IBM推出那臺改變產業的大型主機開始
計算這件事就被切成一層一層
做晶片的人做晶片
做編譯器的人做編譯器
每一層只管自己那一層
這樣分工了60年
他做的事情叫Codesign
中文是協同設計
意思是把演算法
框架
編譯器
晶片
網路
儲存
全部拉到同一張桌子上一起改
他給你的結果是這樣
摸耳定律最好的時候
晶片大概兩年快一倍
十年一百倍
可是十幾年前
電晶體變小之後
不再跟著省電
這個物理紅利先沒了
所以這十年
你實際上大概只拿到十倍
而他說
他們拿到的是一百萬倍
這個數字要講清楚
它量的是什麼
它量的是一整個機櫃
每100萬瓦的電力能吐出多少推論
跨越六個世代疊起來的結果
不是單一顆晶片快了100萬倍
推論就是模型在回答你問題的時候
做的那些計算
但是更重要的是後果
他說快到這種程度之後
研究員才會開始講那句話
那我們幹嘛還挑資料
把整個網際網路都丟給電腦就好
同一套思路
也讓他做過一個
當時看起來很不合理的決定
他說設計Harper那一代晶片的時候
他們決定去蓋
要價幾十億美元的系統
當時全世界根本沒有人
買過那麼貴的電腦
他的原話是
你的市場規模精確的是0
他們還是照第一原理去做了
第一原理的意思是
不看別人現在怎麼做
回到最底層問
物理上這件事應該長成什麼樣子
可是他沒有把這一段
講成一個壓對保的故事
接著講的是他壓錯的那些
NVIDIA的第一代產品
他都不是有點錯
是每件事都做錯了
當時整個產業要往三角形走
他們用曲面
別人有一種叫Z-Buffer的東西
可以判斷哪一個物件在前面
他們沒有
他還有一句講了
33年的口頭禪
我們公司離倒閉只有30天
而他自己認定的真正策略錯誤
不是那顆晶片
是後來決定做手機晶片
那麼生意做起來之後
在3G換到4G那一輪被高通鎖死歸零
有人安慰他說
那些技術後來變成了機器人晶片的祖先
他不接受
他說那是事後合理化
你聽到這裡可能覺得他很硬
但是這一堂他也花了整整兩分鐘
講一件跟晶片完全無關的事
他說他人生的第一份工作
是在一家叫Dennis的美式連鎖餐廳收桌子
他是移民
十幾歲就開始洗碗
收盤子當服務生
然後把這件事
接到一個學生問的問題上
有人問他
這是什麼感覺
他的回答讓現場安靜了一下
他說沒有一個執行長
是從睜開眼睛到閉上眼睛
都樂在其中的
事實是我真正喜歡做的
只有我工作的一層
另外九層很難
而我還是全力去做
我是真的在受苦
接著他給了一個
他自己也知道不討喜的建議
他說我建議你們
不要只追求快樂
也去追求一些痛苦
一些受苦
因為總有一天
世界你的家人
你的公司
你的同事會需要
要你夠強韌
而到了那個時候
你沒有練過
你就沒有那塊肌肉
這一場的溫度
是在一個學生
問到出口管制的時候
整個上來的
出口管制的意思是
美國政府規定
某些等級的晶片
不能賣到某些國家去
有人拿了一個
常見的類比問他
把最高階的GPU
拿去跟核子武器比
他當場拒絕
他說有10億人
在用NVIDIA的GPU
我會推薦GPU
給我的家人
給我的小孩
給我愛的人
我不會推薦原子彈
給任何人
所以那個類比
是站不住的
而如果你從一個
站不住的地方開始想
你後面那一整串思考
都走不完
他更不能接受的是
另一種說法就是
反正我們也會輸
我們還去外面競爭
他的回答是
如果大家都照這個邏輯
那你早上幹嘛起床
他說很久以前
同樣這一套說法
被拿來對付美國的電信業
而今天美國已經沒有
任何基礎的電信技術了
那完全是政策
把他趕出我們的國家
這句話的前半是事實
美國今天確實沒有
一線的行動網絡設備上
但是後半那個因果
結果是他個人的判斷
主流的解釋是好幾件事疊在一起
他最後說了一句很短的話上
大家都應該有AI
沒有人應該有核彈
這個大家可以同意吧
這才是他這一場最有節奏的一段
他要處理的是那種末日式的說法
他先把那個畫面念出來
他會在某一個星期四的晚上
起點突然降臨
然後遊戲結束
有一定機率是人類社會的終結
他停了一下說
拜託
我們都看過沙丘
不用再演一遍
然後他連續講了六次同一句話
說我們完全不知道
這些系統怎麼運作
這不是真的
說技術會在某一個瞬間突然無限強大
師姐 這不是真的
說完全沒有辦法防禦 這不是真的
他說這些人在公開場合活出他們的科幻幻想
而所有人都在依賴他們的話 相信他們的話
這是不負責任的
那他自己的防禦方案是什麼
這裡有一個很反直覺的答案
他支持開放權重的模型
也就是把模型訓練出來的參數公開給大家下載使用
他給的理由不是理想 是資安
他說如果你希望AI是安全的
它就必須是開放的
因為你沒辦法防禦一個黑盒子
你也沒辦法保護一個黑盒子
他要的是反過來
用幾百萬
幾十億個便宜的小模型
把威脅整個包起來
做成一個罩子
這一堂最後的高點
是一次當面的對峙
主持人問他
美國國內的算力其實也很缺
新創大學
獨立的研究團隊根本拿不到
那美國自己不是應該排在出口前面嗎
他說絕對是
主持人說但是沒有發生
他說絕對沒有
全場都笑了
可是他不讓大家笑完
他說這不好笑
這是嚴肅的事
說有人下了單
而我們沒有交貨
這不是真的
你得先下單
然後他給了一個更難聽
也更準確的診斷
他說根本的問題是
這一整套系統
已經不是為了
交付大規模算力而設計的了
史丹佛所有的研究部門
各自為政各自募款
沒有人會分享自己的經費
而沒有任何一筆經費
大到足以買下一臺
你只用一部分時間
但是用的時候需要他非常強的機器
主持人問
沒得錯
他說史丹佛的
主持人提到史丹佛的
效務基金有400多億美元
他的回答是
實際出來交給某一家雲端服務商
那也是每一個學生
每一個研究員都用得到AI超級電腦
我馬上就會這樣做
至於他為什麼要把責任推回去
那句解釋我們留到最後再講
第七堂課的講者
是這門課裡最不像AI產業的人
他叫Scott Nolan
是General Matters的創辦人及執行長
他是一家做油濃縮的公司
他早年在SpaceX做推進系統
之後在創業投資機構Founders Fund
當了十年以上的合夥人
他一上臺沒有先講核能
他先舉證
他說有三個人
是最沒有理由說能源是瓶頸的人
他們上面都說能源是瓶頸
第一個是Sam Altman
他在美國參議院作證的時候說
所有的成本最後都會收斂到能源的成本
電的成本
因為晶片會變便宜
模型會變便宜
但是電是你在跑模型的時候
真正被消耗掉的東西
第二個是黃仁勳
他的誘因明明應該是說晶片才是瓶頸
可是他在Joe Rogan的節目上
被直接問到的時候
回答是他就是瓶頸
第三個是Elon Musk
他手上有一堆瓶頸可以講
他選的能源
主持人補的那一句最簡單
就算你的機房蓋好了
只要電送不進去
就結束了
他接著把過去四年
講的兩次一模一樣的衝擊
第一次是2022年年底的CHAT GPT
那是第一個消費者等級的殺手級應用
一般人第一次真的每天在用AI
但是整條供應鏈完全沒有準備好
他說了一個外行人不會想到的細節
光是把晶片設計送去工廠流片
再把機房架起來
兩年
流片的意思是把設計定稿
送進晶圓廠
做出第一批實體晶片
所以2023年初就出現了算力荒
還短暫出現過電力荒
第二次是最近這一波
他說2025年底到2026年初
那幾個模型出來之後變得是企業
他說你們是學生
人家還有空慢慢玩
但是那些放假回去僱小孩的大人
假放完回到公司開始用它
然後事情就變了
而電從哪裡來
他放了一張圖
把美國過去50年的用電量畫出來
前面30年一路往上
最近20年幾乎是一條平的線
他說我們需要的協律要比中國還陡
得從幾乎完全停滯
變成接近垂直
最快的解法
本來是去找那些已經有電
但是附近沒有人用的地方
這種電有一個名字
擱淺的能源
偏遠地區的水力發電
孤立的地熱
還有西德州的風力
發出來沒有人要
只能浪費掉
而第一批跑去把這些電撿走的人
不是AI公司
是比特幣礦場
他們的條件很簡單
不需要光線
用衛星連線就夠了
他說今天那些好的資源
基本上都被撿光了
而且就算撿到
規模也早就不夠用了
這裡他跟主持人講了一段
我覺得很值得聽的話
主持人說
比特幣挖礦其實是AI的彩排
他們兩個都提到同一件事
很多人只要看到一個團隊
跟加密貨幣有關
就把他們的技術進展一起丟掉
而那很可惜
他舉的例子是一家叫Kuso的公司
這家公司真正在做的事情
從來沒有變過
就是把沒有人要的電
變成有用的東西
他們一開始去油田那邊
把本來要直接燒掉
排進大氣的天然氣拿來發電
那時候那臺機器的產出是比特幣
今天他們把挖礦事業整個賣掉了
同一套本事拿去德州
蓋出一座超過11瓦等級的AI園區
那隔前的電檢完了
下一步是什麼
現在的主流解法是燒天然氣
可是這裡有一個很硬的限制
發電用的燃氣渦輪機
全世界只有幾家做得出來
而他們的訂單已經排到2030年
現在借的是2031年交貨的預約
所以他說接下來兩年
真正的題目只有一個
怎麼在核能來得及之前不要撞牆
那核能為什麼是他認定的長期答案
他的論證方式很務實
如果你要的是
可以一直穩定發電的機載電力
要低碳
還要安全
那把歷史上每一座蓋過的電廠都算進去看統計
核能的碳排屬於最低的那一群
跟風力在統計上分不出高下
安全性也一樣
每發一度電造成的死亡人數
核能跟風力幾乎並列
太陽能才是第一名
他舉了兩個大家都聽過的事故
山梨島
NG美國核管會的結論
偵測不到可以量測的健康影響
福島
官方認定的輻射相關死亡剛好一個人
一般民眾是零
而引發那場事故的海嘯本身
死亡加上失蹤接近兩萬兩千人
他真正想教學生的
其實不是核能
是一個方法
他說不要太在意公開的敘事
也不要停在表層的說法
往下多問幾層
一路問到底
然後問我們到底要解決什麼
他自己示範了一次
AI的瓶頸是什麼
是算力
算力的瓶頸是什麼
是電
多電的長期瓶頸是什麼
是核能
核能的瓶頸是什麼
是燃料
燃料的瓶頸又是什麼
這裡就要講到
優農說了
你從地下挖出來的鈾
裡面真正能拿來發電的那一種原子
連1%都不到
剩下的全部都不是
所以做核燃料的整條路是這樣
開採磨成黃餅
轉成氣體
把能用那種原子比例拉高
再轉回固體
最後壓成燃料丸
中間那一步把比例拉高
就叫濃縮
他自己給濃縮下的定義很好懂
濃縮說穿了就是精煉
只是他分的不是輕油重油
是同一種元素裡不同重量的原子
他的結論是
你把這個推導再做一次
你會發現濃縮在五年的時間尺度上
一路往下就是AI的瓶頸
他推到這一步的時候
丟出了整堂課最大的那個數字
他說你去看做核燃料的那幾個步驟
發現美國今天在濃縮這一步
全球的市佔率不到千分之一
這句話我要幫他講精確一點
因為他只在一種說法下成立
而講精確之後這個故事會更好
不到千分之一
說的是美國人自己擁有的濃縮產能
美國國土上其實是有一座濃縮廠的
在新墨西哥州
年產量大概佔全球的6%
供應美國大約三分之一的需求
但是那座廠
是一家歐洲公司開的
所以真正的問題不是美國沒有
而是美國沒有自己的
他自己的說法也很直接
他說美國完全沒有能力
自己生產核燃料
我們完全依賴歐洲的廠商
甚至到今天還在依賴俄羅斯
即使有制裁
我們還是得進口
因為我們真的需要
你可以停在這裡
想一下這個畫面
一個正在跟全世界搶算力
把AI當成國家級競賽的國家
他的核燃料
得跟他正在制裁的對象買
這怎麼變成這樣的
答案是這一趟最有戲的地方
因為不是別人搶走的
是美國自己關掉的
時間倒回1960到70年代
美國幾乎壟斷了
整個非蘇聯世界的濃縮產能
1985年還有六成四
之後這條線一路往下
90年代中期剩不到四成
2001年剩兩成三
2008年剩一成四
中間發生了什麼
國領圍牆倒了
俄羅斯要裁減核彈頭
於是美國推了一個計劃
名字叫Megatons to Megawatts
中文可以說成
從百萬噸到百萬瓦
做法是把俄羅斯核彈頭裡的材料取出來
稀釋掉
變成發電用的燃料
丟進美國的反應爐去發電
500公噸的武器級材料
大約等於2萬顆彈頭
最後供應了美國核燃料的大約一半
同一段時間
美國自己那套老技術非常耗電
做同樣一份工要多燒50倍的電
成本上完全打不過
經營的公司開始虧錢
最後一座在2013年停止濃縮
這裡要補兩句話才誠實
法國的同型工廠2012年也關了
所以那是物理
不是美國獨有的失誤
而美國其實有做新一代的離心機
在2009年被政府拒絕貸款擔保之後就死掉了
他對這整體式的評語很輕
但是很重
他說我想當時大家心裡都有一個計劃
需要的時候再把濃縮找回來就好
而這個需要來得比任何人預期的都快太多
2025年8月
美國坑塔基州的帕杜卡
一塊100英畝的土地上辦了凍土儀式
這座城市
就是美國最後那座濃縮場關掉的地方
凍土的是他那家兩年前才成立的公司
而2026年1月
美國能源部把一份為期10年
按照進度分批付款的9億美元合約給了他們
把產能蓋回來
這裡也要講清楚結構
那不是政府開一張9億美元的支票給一家新創
那是一份競標拿到的任務訂單
而且同一天能源部一共發了三張9億
總額27億美元
加加公司未來幾年會需要大約1000個人
一半在加州做工程
一半在肯塔基做營建
所有人都在講AI會消滅工作
這裡有一條往相反方向長的線
他自己收在一句話上
他說回頭看1950、60年代
我們本來該做兩件事
上太空
還有擁有便宜又乾淨的能源
我們做到了其中一件
而且現在我們終於在做第二件
最後一趟
主持人用一首歌開唱
他放的是四海一家
那首1985年
威爾伊索比亞集荒路的合唱曲
然後他說
今天這位來賓是科技業的Quincy Jones
Quincy Jones這首歌的製作人
主持人給的理由是
他是全世界最會處理一群超有才華
又超難搞的人的那個人
那部紀錄片裡有一幕很好
然後錄影那天晚上
接近午夜
Quincy走進錄音室
指著門上他自己手寫貼上去的一張紙
說念一下那個
紙上寫的是
把你的自尊留在門口
今天坐在臺上的是Ben Horowitz
Industry Horowitz的共同創辦人
那是今天全世界最大的科技創業投資機構之一
而他更早的身份是一個創業者
跟Mark Andreessen一起做過一家叫Loud Cloud
來改名Osware的公司
2007年賣給了惠普
這一堂跟前面三堂都不一樣的
前面三堂談的系統是機器
這一堂談的系統是錢和人
他說2009年他們開這家公司的時候
是衝著兩個當時所有人都同意的共識去的
第一個共識是
創業投資這門生意對出資人來說是好產品
回報很不錯
可是對創業者來說是爛產品
因為除了給錢以外幾乎什麼都不做
第二個共識更關鍵
當時業界公認每一年
全世界大概只會有15家科技公司
做到1億美元的營收
而這15家貢獻了整個行業將近全部的回報
你想想這句話的意思
如果每年真的只有15家
整個行業的玩法就只有一種
想辦法擠進其中幾家的股東名單
他們賭的是這個數字會變
他們相信軟體會吃掉世界
所以每年做到那個規模的公司
會從15家變成200家
這裡要說明一下
那個15家的說法不是他們發明的
是當年整個業界共用的一組數字
他們做的事情是
站在同一組數字前面
賭它會失效
他的第一個設計是關於權力怎麼分
傳統的機構是合夥制
幾個合夥人共享收益
也共享控制權
大勢都要所有人同意
他的判斷是
一旦控制權是共享的
這個組織就再也改不動了
他講了一句很誠實的話
任何一次重組
一定有人會恨他
不是因為那些人不好
是因為沒有人喜歡失去權利
所以他們的設計是
收益大家一起分
但是控制權集中
第二個設計更好笑
新基金最大的問題是
沒有人認識你
而創業者最需要的東西之一
是能不能見到大公司的採購
他們做了兩件事
第一件是不給自己發薪水
創投通常用管理費付自己很高的薪水
他們想的是
如果我們什麼都不拿
把那些錢拿去蓋一個人脈網路呢
第二件事是那個漏洞
他們前一家公司賣給了惠普
所以認識惠普企業簡報中心裡面的人
那是大企業專門用來接待客戶的地方
他說他們就每個星期打電話過去
問一句話
這禮拜有哪些公司要來
可以給我們電話嗎
把那些公司請到自己這邊來
是看完所有的新創
他說我們準備好甜甜圈
全部搞得一點都不像創投
那些大企業愛死了
這一段只有他自己講過
沒有別的來源可以對照
而且他們還在業界非常不受歡迎
他說其他創投給他們取了難聽的綽號
然後他自己還火上加油
寫了一篇文章
直接列舉創投做的哪幾件事他很討厭
他說每一次見出之人
對方都跟他講同一件事
我們去見別家創投
他們只想講你們
而且講的都是難聽話
他的反應是
那太棒了
然後他給了一句
我覺得整堂課最反直覺的話
他說因為他們太恨我了
所以他們不願意抄
我們正在做而且正在成功的東西
值得停一下
一般人會把被討厭算成成本
他把它算成時間
當你的對手因為情緒上的理由拒絕承認
你做對了
你就多買到好幾年
組成補了一個很妙的旁證
他當時人在對接另一家老牌創投上班
他把Andreason Horowitz的新聞
拿給自家的行銷長看
我們也應該做這個
行銷長看完說
那只是簡報會而已
那只是行銷
他講完創投的歷史之後
丟出了對整個系列最重要的一句話
他說我整個質押力
關於科技公司
唯一確定的一件事就是
你不能靠砸錢解決問題
如果有人領先你兩年
你沒有辦法僱
一千個工程師追上去
他用的比喻是
九個女人
沒有辦法在一個月裡
生出一個小孩
有些事情就是
不能分開來同時做
而且人一多
光是溝通的成本
就會把時間吃光
然後他把這條鐵律推翻掉
他說有了AI
這件事真的變了
你現在可以靠砸錢解決問題
因為只要你有夠多的GPU
和夠多的資料
你基本上什麼問題都能解
這句話的後果很大
他自己接著推下去
程式碼不再是護城河了
使用者的界面也不再是護城河了
那你的進入障礙到底還剩下什麼
他順手回答了一個大家常問的問題
會不會需求撐不住
他說你們很多人太年輕
沒有用過以前的企業軟體
光是部署就要兩年
至少一百萬美元起跳
那當然會限制需求
我們當一個技術好用到現在這種程度
需求就沒有上限
那如果程式碼和界面都不是護城河了
還剩下什麼
他給的答案是網路效應
可是他馬上把這個詞
最難的地方講出來
網路效應的意思是
一個東西用的人愈多
他對每一個人就愈有價值
通訊軟體是最典型的例子
你留在上面不是因為他做得多好
是因為你想找的人都在上面
他說如果一個網路上有10億人
他當然很有價值
這誰都知道
但是貝爾當年怎麼賣出第一支電話
那時候根本沒有人可以講話
系統一個網路
才是真正難的那一部分
這裡他也說了一句
對年輕創業者很不留情
但是很誠實的評論
他說他認識20歲的Mark Zuckerberg
如果那時候他做的不是一門有網路效應的生意
那根本不可能成功
他當時就是不夠好
正因為那門生意有垂直起飛的性質
他才有時間長成後來的樣子
這句話聽起來刻薄
可是他在講一件對每個人都有用的事
一個好的結構會替你買到飯廚和長大的事
他花了不少時間講文化
而他對文化的定義
跟大部分公司牆上貼的那一套完全不一樣
他說文化不是信念是行為
不是我們有誠信我們互相支援那種話
而是我們具體怎麼做事
我們進不進辦公室
5點下班還是待久一點
有人問我一個問題
我是馬上回
還是一個禮拜之後才回
這些才是文化
他的收入我覺得非常實用
他說如果你有一個明確的標準
那有人做不到的時候
處理起來很簡單
可是如果你沒有標準
別人又沒有照你希望的方式做事
你就只會生氣
然後公司就開始內鬥
開始政治化
因為他為什麼可以下班
可是我們從來沒有說過
他要留下來
他也很直白的說
公司不是民主
他討厭共同執行長
因為你需要有人來打破僵局
但是他馬上把界限畫清楚
而這條線畫得很好
他說國家不一樣
公司倒了就倒了
惠普的兩位創辦人走了
後面的領導人不夠好
公司就結束了
沒關係那只是一家公司
國家必須撐得比那更久
所以寧可把權力分散
讓這套制度扛得住一個壞的領導者
他還處理了一個
現在很多人在問的問題
市場上有一種說法是
AI會把所有的軟體公司一次做掉
他的回答很直接
他說這是華爾街的看法
而只要華爾街想的跟硅谷不一樣
那個價差就值很多錢
何況華爾街總是錯的
他舉的例子是一家做商務差旅的公司
叫Navon
他自己是那家公司的董事
要做這門生意
你得跟全世界每一家航空公司
每一家飯店建立供應鏈關係
還得有很舊的系統
最後你還要賣給一個叫差旅經理的人
他問了一句
Anthropic會去建一條通路來賣給差旅經理嗎
他自己的答案是
遍地都是金磚
他們不會彎腰去撿一塊銀磚
他解釋華爾傑的機制那一段也很好懂
但其實是投票機
長期是稱重機
這是巴菲特把格拉汗的想法
濃縮出來的說法
因為華爾街買的是敘事
不是事實
而他形容那種
一起被賣掉的狀況
用了一句很老的行話
球車停到門口的時候
屋裡的人全部都會被抓走
不是隻有真的犯了罪的那集
斯坦克走到這裡
我要把上一集的一句話
拿回來對照
上一集
OpenAI的執行長
講到權力集中的時候說
那是這個時代的吸引子狀態
就是不管你怎麼走
最後都會被拉過去的
那個結局
而他說即使我們會是
那少數極甲之一
這也不是我們該容忍的事
這一集Ben Horowitz用了幾乎一模一樣的詞
而出完全相反的結論
他說歷史上權力的集中
一直是對人類最糟的事情
可是他接著說
所以我最害怕的是
我們作為一個國家失敗
我們太害怕
我們過度管制
我們把資料中心叫停
然後中國贏了
他的最後一句是
恐懼本身造成的問題
可能比大家害怕的東西還糟
兩邊都反對集中
只是一邊怕的是公司
另一邊怕的是國家
而兩邊也都沒有回答對方的問題
上一集那些人沒有處理
如果你慢下來
對手不慢怎麼辦
這一集這些人也沒有處理
如果贏的那一方本來就是你自己
那又怎麼辦
我們回到黃仁勳那句還沒講完的話
他被問到那是誰的錯
他說是史丹佛的
然後他解釋了為什麼
他說當你說某件事是誰的錯
你就把解決他的權利給了那個人
說的你的錯
就是在授權你自己去解決它
四位講者站在四個
源泉不同的位置上
可是他們合起來給了同一個答案
這個時代的槓桿是真的變長了
長到一個人可以在五天裡
重做一件當年要十個人做兩年的事
長到一家兩年前才成立的公司
可以補一個國家幾乎歸零的產業
但是每一根槓桿的支點
都在別人手上
而且都要付租金
Ben Horowitz給學生的建議
我覺得是四堂課最好的收尾
他說你把AI想成電
假設你活在通電之前的世界
六點就得回家
因為天要黑了
哪裡都去不了
現在這個全新的世界要來了
去把這個技術搞懂
然後想清楚
你真正在乎世界上的什麼
生物材料火箭都可以
然後把工具帶在身上去做那件事
最後問你一個問題
如果現在有一根長道
可以撬動一個產業的槓桿
放在你手上
而你也知道支點是租來的
你會拿它去撬什麼
留言告訴我
下集我們會看完這門課
剩下的幾堂
我會放在同一個播放清單裡
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
下次見